well this might be the best looking
airplane you'll ever board we showed you
spirit's new plane featuring country
star
brett young it was at mccarran last week
well tonight brett and this plane will
be on the runway
in florida for a special virtual concert
you can watch
right here from your living room yeah
there's the plane you can see his face
is on the side of it
we spoke with brett yesterday so the
last full show he played was last march
in berlin like
so many other performers so he's really
excited to play tonight and said there
will be a lot of surprises
yeah we're gonna really kind of put
together a show that mimics as much as
possible
um what we were doing when this whole
thing came to a halt back in march
of last year so uh it'll be a big party
uh it'll be a very different stage than
we've ever been on
and there'll be two versions of me one
will be myself and
the other will be a giant floating head
on a spirit carolina
yeah i think a lot of people are trying
to figure out how to reserve that spot
like three rows and four rows from the
back
one of the windows that's on my forehead
i thought he was joking i think that
actually is where he would reserve
though so
uh those will go pretty quick he's been
working on new music too during the
pandemic
he also has a one-year-old daughter
she's gorgeous
and just announced another one on the
way so he said things are a little
different now in his world
the one thing that has changed
dramatically is um
going out the night before shows now
with with a one-year-old running around
it's like you
you you try to limit the time that
you're gone as much as possible so
um it'll be uh it'll be a quick in and
out
um but it's it's worth it to you know
even when you feel like you need a break
because one year olds are a lot
the second you're away from when you
miss them so um
uh sitting home still for a little bit
i'm on daddy duty
uh tonight and then uh and then off to
work
so cute so you can watch that concert on
livestream tonight
spirit.com fly away it's there on the
screen
tonight five o'clock our time and it is
free
i was getting so many messages from
viewers and just
from everybody about what he was like
because his songs are so
sweet and he really is so it was really
fun to talk to you guys
he seems like it and you know you said
so cute was that that he's a
daddy or that he's just so cute well
all of the above and uh john i wanted to
make sure the viewers understand that
the
sweaty the hoodie that he was wearing
said violent gentlemen we don't
want to give folks the wrong idea what's
that all about so that is
a hockey company that is based in
southern california but it was started
by a fellow named george peros who
played for the anaheim ducks back in the
day and actually used to live here in
las vegas
now works for the nhl so that is that's
the sweater that
brett was repping so okay apparently
he's a hockey guy alex he's hot so
that's another
step in the right direction yeah well
he's from anaheim so
maybe that's the connection yeah he used
to play baseball full circle
he he does it all sherry well we should
convince him to be a golden knights fan
there you go
right yeah this year yeah yeah yeah
they're just tail feathers